[Music]
[Applause]
and one of my frequent guests is
actually Albert Breer senior NFL
reporter and lead content strategist wow
that is an interesting title at the mmqb
here's what I'll tell you about Albert I
think he's the best out there I think
he's the best NFL writer out there
period And I know that that might sound
I read a lot
I read everything Albert writes because
he's all over it check him out on social
media at Albert Brier Albert good
morning how are you hey Ross I'm a
little tired how about you yeah well you
had to write your column last night
that's a nice that's a nice hotel room
tell me about your hotel room where are
you yeah this is the this is the
Residence Inn near uh where I do TV on
Sunday night and honestly like the
reason why people have asked me why do
you stay in a hotel on Sunday night and
the reason why honestly is I can't
afford to lose the hour commute the hour
that I would driving home so I do TV
until about like 12 30 a.m and I write
till somewhere between 5 and 6 30 every
more every Monday morning and so losing
that hour to going from TV back to my
house would be like devastating so yeah
here I am at the hotel so how many hours
did you sleep three
three is about right yeah I think to
this point it was like maybe like
6 45 to just before 10 so a little over
three wow love it so we're heading it up
for you Ross I had to get up for you I
appreciate we're getting your fresh
thoughts I'm glad I said how much I
liked it how good I think you are
um at Albert Brewer of course on social
media all right I want to start with the
Bucks and Packers which which loss is
more concerning which team are you more
concerned about Brady in the bucks or
Rogers and the Packers and why
I'm
like I I feel like I I feel like the
Bucks are the right answer right because
like with the Packers I do think that
you look at the roster and you can say
okay
well some of this is built in and some
of this was planned right like so the
package you look at it you say they're
pacing some of their older guys back
like David back tiari and Elkton Jenkins
they didn't push those guys back on the
field before they were ready they sort
of paced those guys back
um on defense jahir Alexander still
needs to get his feet underneath him so
like they like I feel like the Packers
have a bunch of older players they were
kind of working back under the field and
then they're committing reps to younger
players like Romeo Dobbs and Christian
Watson and part of the plan and
replacing Devante Adams was we're gonna
go all in on some younger guys and we're
gonna give them time to develop so at
least with the Packers you see a plan
there where this isn't ideal by any
means don't get me wrong but like you
could see some of the bumps coming
whereas with the Box
it feels like are they getting old like
you know when you look at the the
inactive list yesterday right like look
who's on the inactive list
you know it's guys like Julio Jones that
where the question is how much he has
left in the tank and what's Leonard four
not gonna look like at the end of the
year they're really relying on him right
now and oh by the way the offensive line
isn't close to what it was a year ago
and you you see
um Brady yelling at those guys in the
sideline
um there's no Ali marpett or Ryan Jensen
or Alex Cappa out there
um I just look at the totality of the
box and then you look at like where the
Packers are and it's really easy to see
where the Packers could fight through
this and wind up being better for going
through this is there a scenario there
Ross where what the Bucks were going
through is like for the betterment of
the team you know what I'm saying that's
my bigger question probably not
um it's funny though as you talk I
always get more questions so we didn't
really ever talk about this is there
anything Aaron Rodgers could have done
to keep Devonte Adams I guess as you're
talking and you mentioned Devonta Adams
replacing him in my head Albert
if Tom Brady was the quarterback of the
Green Bay Packers
Devonta Adams would not have left I
don't care how much he likes Derek Carr
or how close they are Tom Brady would
not have let him leave like somehow that
would have happened does it say
something about Rogers that he wasn't
able to keep Devonte Adams on some level
you know the weird thing about it is I
can still remember when all that was
happening and you talked to people
around Rogers and um you talk to people
with the Packers and everybody almost
seemed to resign to it happening you
know what I mean like and I know it
hadn't been public and everything else
but like you know when you when you
started to kind of turn over some more
rocks and you're always trying to figure
out like when these big bombs go off
like how did this happen how steady a
thing this was and how like after Rogers
was so upset about the team not building
for the for for for for the now you know
and how a whole part of all the drama in
2021 was I want you to build on my
timeline I want you to build the way
that the Bucks are building for Brady
where you're not worried about what the
roster looks like three years from now
now all of a sudden you're totally okay
you know Devonte Adams going out the
door
um it just it felt like when it happened
it was such an inevitability you know
what I mean like and so I think that
that was the big thing like I
I I don't know that there was anything
that that that Aaron could have done to
stop it now would it have happened if
Brady was was there I
it's it's hard to say you know because
Brady lost guys over the years too and
you can remember how upset he was you
know I can go all the way back to you
know when when they when they when they
let David Gibbons walk out the door and
then they trade Dion Branch you know
what I mean like a good point there are
a ton of examples of that where Brady
was upset when guys left
um you know I for one reason or another
like Roger seemed really at peace with
this and it seemed like an inevitability
to everybody concerned which I mean
tells me that Devonte Adams had sort of
been contemplating this for a while
wanting to go back to the West Coast and
not just play with Derek Carr but be
closer to home too is Brady we're
talking with Albert Brewer senior NFL
reporter lead content strategist for the
mmqb
is Tom Brady on some level
hurting his reputation or Legacy a
little bit you know he skips 11 days
during training camp and now he skips
the walk through Saturday he's at
Kraft's wedding Friday night you know
because I was up in New England parts of
05 and 06 Albert people ask me about him
all the time and my whole thing is like
he's a total psycho he's all in like
he's he's all in he's not all in Albert
like this is the first year I can ever
remember where he's not all in and he's
kind of hurting he's hurting my argument
that he's successful because he's all in
because he's not all in this year well
let me ask you this I'm going to turn
this around on you then Ross like
you know he was the guy who like I
remember Rodney Harrison always telling
that story like Rodney would walk into
the locker room or into the weight room
at 5 30 in the morning and Brady would
be in there and say good afternoon to
him you know what I mean like those are
always the stories you heard about Brady
when he was younger and I think Brady
always had this sort of this this Equity
um you know and whatever team he was on
with the amount of work he was putting
in where he could get after whoever he
wanted to get after because they knew
this guy's putting in more than me right
you know well and really and really what
I always tell people is I think the
biggest reason for his success is the
other guys don't want to let him down
right because you know how important it
is to him and how much time he puts in
you don't want to be the one that screws
it up for him so let me ask you this if
you're one of those linemen sitting on
that bench yesterday is it in the back
of your head this guy wasn't at the walk
through yesterday a little bit yeah I
mean you're not thinking about that in
the moment and it's not like this and
it's and Ross it's not like that's the
thing about it's like it's not this guy
wasn't the walkthrough because there's
some important Family Matter this guy
was at a party in New York City on
Friday night and he couldn't be bothered
to get back here for that it was
actually a surprise wedding it was not a
party was surprise wedding yeah and I
know what you're saying but like were
you there you know huh Were you invited
were you there I got my invite got lost
in the mail I don't know
um but that's the thing is like I don't
you feel like even if like five years
ago
even if five years ago Tom Brady decided
I have to go to this thing on Friday
night with Robert Kraft right don't you
think he would have made the arrangement
to get to the walkthrough of course like
on Saturday morning and I don't know
what time I walked through but it's not
at 7am you know what I mean like no you
get there by 8 A.M he he could have
flown back that night he flies private
flies private yeah he could have got he
made a conscious decision to not go back
he easily could have gone back I don't
know maybe his family's in New York and
he wanted to spend an extra day with him
I I don't know what his deal is I mean I
mean but that's the thing that's that's
the thing me is like I
I it's just now it's getting to the
point where and look a big part of this
like part of the reason why he's on the
East Coast
um and I don't know many people know
this but part of the reason he's on the
east coast and went to the Bucks not the
Chargers uh two years ago was because
his son jack lives in New York and he
wanted to be able to go back and forth
and sometimes on off days he'll go see
his son jack in New York which is
incredibly important and it's great that
he's doing that to me like that's in a
different category than going to like a
party on a Friday night you know what I
mean like and going to a social event on
a Friday night not making it back for
the Saturday walkthrough so I do wonder
about some of those things and you don't
want to delve into you know somebody's
personal life and everything else but I
just know this like this is a guy who
like generally wouldn't miss anything
and now we've started to see like this
string of things that have happened and
then the way he's talking is different
too like if you listen to like he would
never really talk about the end in
finite time finite terms you know like
now he's doing it you know what I mean
like now now he's actually talking about
the end and so it's just you sort of
it's like that old saying where where is
it Ross like if a player's talking about
retirement he sort of already is retired
well that's what Parcells always said
you know I didn't even get a chance to
watch the video Albert because I was
doing stuff yesterday and watching games
but I saw where you said things have
gone sideways a little bit between Mac
Jones and the Patriots explain
yeah so I you know I think a big part of
this is who Mac is Right Mac is a big
why guy like he wants to know why you're
doing something why are we running this
why am I being coached this why wait why
is this person being hired why are you
handling my injury this way and
New England's never been a Big Y place
as I think you know right yes I don't
know that Bill's ever been big on giving
everybody a full explanation for what
he's doing they intentionally do not
they don't want they don't want you to
know why they're doing what they do
because then you'll tell other people
and they look at it as a competitive
advantage that you don't know why
they're doing what they're doing right
so like I think like you know Mac had a
great rookie year and you know he was
really close with Josh McDaniels and
obviously Josh got a lot out of him and
I think Mac had a ton of respect for the
job that Matt the the Mac had a ton of
respect for the job that Josh did in
developing him so this is obviously all
very important to him the way it is to
any quarterback and he knows how
important the year one to year two
transition is how much growth there can
be
and so I think a big part of it for him
was
wait a second why are you hiring a
defensive defensive coach is my
offensive coordinator why are you hiring
a special teams coach as my quarterbacks
coach
why are we running a different offense
now why are we doing things differently
I had a lot of success last year why are
we building on what we did last year why
why why why why right and I I don't
think this isn't a knock on Mac this is
that generation right like this is that
generation where they always act ask why
most players who go into New England
don't have the collateral to ask those
questions right you're just trying to
make it and that's the first round pick
mac played at Alabama Mack was this way
at Alabama with Nick Saban so like I
think coming out of his rookie year
there was I think with all the change
and everything else in New England there
was some natural friction there and so
that was the background and then there
was disagreement over the handling of
his injury and whether or not he should
get surgery
and so I think that that's in what way
he thought he should they thought he
shouldn't or vice versa no vice versa
they wanted him to get the tight rug
down this is initially after he first
got hurt
um with a high ankle sprain it was
thought to be a pretty severe high ankle
sprain and what the tightrope surgery
does it doesn't really it doesn't really
fix your injury it accelerates your
recovery and it makes it so you can get
back on the field faster and Max saw
Jalen hurts into a tongue Below in his
in his position room in Alabama go
through that surgery now when Tua got it
the second time two got it twice he came
back and dislocated his health hip so
he's seen like he's seen guys go through
this he's seen The Good The Bad of it
and he thought I'm going to be better
off just rehabbing the injury and there
was some level of disagreement there now
because the high ankle spring didn't
wind up being quite as severe as
as um as initially thought
it wound up being less of an issue
because now he's probably going to be
able to get back within the time frame
that the surgery would have put him back
on the field but there was some level of
disagreement on that too and I think
that's to me like the backdrop for the
Bailey zappy thing and why Bill
Belichick refuses to say Max getting his
job back you notice that like how many
times he's been asked that like he
refuses to say Max getting his job done
I think Max getting his job back I think
that there's a little bit of a a lesson
being taught here where it's look we're
putting a fourth round rookie from
Western Kentucky out there look what
happens when he does what we tell him to
and I think to their credit Matt
Patricia and Joe judge are doing a
pretty good job with the guy you know
having the guy ready to go and playing
this way so I think that there's a
little bit of a I'd say I'd say a lesson
being learned here you know what I mean
or unless I'm being taught here where I
think the the Patriots would like Matt
to take something from all of this and
we'll see which way this pushes the
relationship between Mac and the
Patriots whether it's a good thing or a
bad thing two two quick ones Panthers
how many guys they trade in the next
couple weeks
I I don't think it's gonna be a fire
sale I think one of the things that's
unique about the panther situation is a
lot of their guys would be good that
they have now and you can look at the
roster would actually be good building
blocks for whoever the next coach is
like like a lot of their best players
like Brian Burns so the two guys they've
got the most calls on are Brian Burns
and DJ Moore the pass rusher and the
receiver
Burns is 24 years old he's going into a
contract here but or he's in a contract
year but they will they can franchise
them after the year
why would you give up a 24 year old pass
rusher right unless you're getting
something phenomenal in return DJ Moore
same thing I think he's 25. he's on a
pretty team-friendly contract now they
just signed him to an extension so why
would you get rid of a number one
receiver on a team friendly contract
with term left the guys who are younger
than that around rookie contracts Nikki
kuanu
um you know JC horn Derek Brown those
guys are on rookie contracts so there's
no reason to trade trade those guys you
have really good players on cheap
cheap cheap deals for the next few years
and so I think a lot of the guys that
they're getting calls on are guys that
would be good for the next coach to have
and might help you lure the next coach
might make your job attractive to the
next coach so I think that the number of
guys that they really be motivated to
look at moving
um is pretty limited and it'd be a
Robbie Anderson who I mean maybe they're
gonna probably put him out on the corner
like a like a couch in college after
what happened yesterday and
um and then I mean I mean the other one
would be Christian McCaffrey who's
interesting because he's like like he is
the type of guy you would move if you
were that franchise because he's an
aging running back and how much is he
going to have left when the next coach
is ready to win and all of that but he's
the face of the franchise and how much
are people really willing to give up for
him too is a whole other question yeah I
mean that's the thing is that's the
thing is Ross is like if somebody throws
you like a third round pick or a fourth
is that worth it or would you rather
give Steve Wilkes a chance to win with
Christian McCaffrey you know what I mean
like I think it's a fair question to ask
thank you Albert check him out on social
media at Albert Brier make sure you
check out his column he just slept three
hours so that you could have an awesome
column and he could come on the show
thank you man really appreciate it all
right thanks Ross